Ми вважаємо, що квантові комп'ютери дозволять нам розв'язувати деякі задачі швидше, ніж ми можемо це робити лише з класичними комп'ютерами. Але
розуміти як — це непросто. Сьогодні в Qiskit у класі ми спробуємо розкрити джерело потужності
квантових обчислень, розглянувши один із самих перших
алгоритмів. Ласкаво просимо до Qiskit у класі. У цій серії ми використаємо Qiskit, щоб дослідити деякі фундаментальні
концепції, які зазвичай розглядаються в курсах, пов'язаних із квантовими обчисленнями. До кожного відео додається інтерактивний модуль,
посилання на який є в описі нижче. Тож обов'язково перевір його. Якщо ти багато чув про квантові комп'ютери, то ти, мабуть,
чув, що вони можуть використовувати квантові явища, як-от суперпозиція, заплутаність та інтерференція, для розв'язання
задач способами, недоступними класичним комп'ютерам. Але як саме ці властивості допомагають? У 1985 році David Deutsch був
першим, хто показав, як це може відбуватися. Він придумав те, що зараз називається алгоритмом Deutsch, який міг розв'язати
задачу ефективніше, ніж класичний алгоритм. Сьогодні ми розглянемо алгоритм Deutsch та
пізніше розширення під назвою алгоритм Deutsch-Jozsa, і дослідимо, як унікально квантові властивості qubit'ів
можуть бути використані на користь квантового комп'ютера. Потім ми запустимо ці алгоритми на справжньому квантовому комп'ютері за допомогою Qiskit.
Існують і інші квантові алгоритми, які також демонструють теоретичну перевагу над відомими класичними алгоритмами. І не всі вони працюють
на тих самих принципах, що й ті, які ми розглянемо сьогодні. Тому те, що ми дізнаємося сьогодні, не пояснює загалом, як працює квантовий
комп'ютер, але це допомагає нам почати розуміти, як принципи квантової механіки можна поєднати, щоб
створити потужний квантовий комп'ютер. Перш ніж заглиблюватися в алгоритм Deutsch, давайте спочатку подумаємо, чим квантові комп'ютери
відрізняються від класичних і як це може дати нам перевагу у розв'язанні певних
задач. Одна відмінність полягає в тому, що квантові біти, звані qubit'ами, можуть перебувати в станах суперпозиції. Замість того щоб бути
обмеженим лише станом нуля або станом одиниці, як класичний біт, qubit
може перебувати в стані суперпозиції нуля та одиниці одночасно. Ми записуємо цей стан ось так,
де a та b — комплексні числа, суми квадратів яких дорівнюють одиниці, і що більше
qubit'ів, то більше розширюється цей розрив. Два класичні біти можуть перебувати лише в одному з
чотирьох можливих станів: 0 0, 0 1, 1 0 або 1
1. Два qubit'и можуть перебувати в суперпозиції всіх чотирьох із цих класично дозволених станів, що
записується ось так. Загалом, класична система з n бітів може перебувати лише в одній із 2 у степені n можливих
комбінацій нулів та одиниць. Квантова система з n qubit'ів може перебувати в суперпозиції всіх 2 у степені n із цих
станів. Масштабування є експоненційним. Тож навіть якби у нас було лише 10 qubit'ів, вони
могли б перебувати в стані суперпозиції 2 у степені 10, що дорівнює 1024 можливим комбінаціям нулів та
одиниць. Експоненційне масштабування простору станів qubit'ів називається квантовим
паралелізмом і частково відповідає за перевагу квантових комп'ютерів над класичними. Але квантовий
комп'ютер — це не просто масивний паралельний процесор. Те, що qubit'и в квантовому комп'ютері можуть перебувати в
суперпозиції експоненційно великої кількості станів, не означає, що ми маємо доступ до всієї інформації в кожному з цих
станів. Оскільки вимірювання колапсує систему до одного стану або іншого, давайте
подивимося, як це відбувається на простій задачі. Припустімо, є якась машина, якій
можна подати один біт. Тоді вона застосує якусь функцію до цього біта і видасть інший одиночний біт. Машина
знаходиться всередині чорного ящика, до якого ми не маємо доступу. Ми маємо доступ лише до біта,
який ми подаємо x, і до біта, який ящик видає f
від x. Ми хочемо з'ясувати, яку саме функцію f застосовує машина.
Існує чотири можливі функції, які відображають один біт на інший одиночний біт.
Тож, щоб дізнатися, яка це функція, ми можемо просто подати нуль і подивитися, чи видасть вона нуль або одиницю. Потім подати
одиницю і зробити те саме. Кожен із цих двох кроків називається запитом. Це
один зі способів порівнювати класичні та квантові алгоритми через так звану модель запитів, де ми порівнюємо кількість
запитів, які кожен із алгоритмів повинен зробити до чорного ящика, щоб розв'язати задачу. Отже, у цьому випадку наш
класичний метод потребував двох запитів до ящика, щоб дізнатися функцію. Подивімося, чи зможемо ми зробити краще, якщо використати квантовий
комп'ютер для запиту до чорного ящика. Замість того щоб спочатку подавати нуль, а потім одиницю,
квантовий комп'ютер може подати в ящик qubit, який перебуває в суперпозиції нуля та
одиниці. Тобто фактично ми подаємо в ящик обидва входи з одним запитом. Але
чи означає це, що ми можемо дізнатися функцію лише за один запит?
На жаль, це не так. Ми побачимо, чому ця ідея не спрацьовує, коли перевіримо її на квантовому комп'ютері. Ми зробимо
circuit із двох qubit'ів. Qubit нуль, представлений тут цією верхньою лінією, буде нашим вхідним станом X, який ми подаємо до
чорного ящика, показаного тут maroon gate з міткою UF. Gate UF
призначений прийняти qubit нуль як вхідний стан X, потім застосувати перетворення до qubit'а один, яке переводить
стан нуля до стану f від x. Тому, якщо qubit 1 почав у стані
нуля, то виходом є x на qubit'і 0 та f від x на qubit'і 1. Отже, щоб знайти f від x для
обох x=0 та x=1 одночасно, ми можемо спробувати помістити qubit 0 у суперпозицію 0 та 1 перед тим,
як подати його до чорного ящика. Це робиться за допомогою цього червоного Hadamard gate, який перетворює нульовий стан на 1/√2
(|0⟩ + |1⟩). Тому після gate чорного ящика ми повинні мати суперпозицію обох
f від 0 та f від 1 на qubit'і 1. Вимірюючи два qubit'и, ми сподіваємося отримати відповідь на
питання: яка функція знаходиться всередині чорного ящика? Використаємо примітив Qiskit sampler, щоб запустити
circuit і отримати результат. Ми можемо обрати кількість запусків circuit'а, яка називається samples, змінивши цей
параметр, який тут називається shots.
WEBVTT
Це еквівалентно кількості запитів, які ми робимо до чорного ящика. Подивімося, чи спрацює лише один запит.
Ось результат. Ми виміряли qubit 0 як нуль. Тобто це було
вхідне значення x, а qubit 1 — як 1, що було вихідним значенням f від x. Тож тепер ми
знаємо, що f від 0 дорівнює 1. Але що щодо f від 1? Ось у чому проблема. Як тільки
ми виміряли стан, суперпозиції колапсували, і ми змогли виміряти лише одну частину функції за
один запит. Це не дає нам усієї інформації, необхідної для визначення того, яка це функція. Нам би знадобився
другий запит до ящика для цього. Тому, хоча принцип квантового паралелізму дозволяє нам одночасно
мати чорний ящик, що обчислює f від 0 та f від 1, ми не маємо доступу до обох
цих відповідей. Самого квантового паралелізму недостатньо. Алгоритм Deutsch
показує, як ми можемо використовувати квантовий паралелізм дещо інакше, щоб дізнатися про функцію всередині чорного ящика. Ми не зможемо
дізнатися точно, яка це функція, але зможемо дізнатися щось нове про неї за
один запит, чого не вдалося б із класичним комп'ютером. Почнемо з того, що подивимося на таблицю чотирьох можливих
функцій, що відображають один біт на інший одиночний біт. Тут ти бачиш, що дві функції — f_sub_1 та f_sub_4 — завжди
повертають єдине значення незалежно від вхідного стану. Ці дві функції ми називаємо
константними. f_sub_2 та f_sub_3 повертатимуть або нуль, або одиницю залежно від
стану x. Ці дві функції ми називаємо збалансованими. Алгоритм Deutsch
визначає, чи є функція константною або збалансованою, вносячи кілька розумних коригувань до circuit'а, який ми використовували
раніше. Ось circuit. Він починається з підготовки qubit'а 0 у стані 1/√2
(|0⟩ + |1⟩) за допомогою Hadamard, як і раніше, і qubit'а 1 у стані 1/√2 (|0⟩ - |1⟩)
за допомогою not gate, за яким іде Hadamard.
Отже, повний стан у цей момент виглядає ось так, де цей вираз — стан qubit'а 0, а
цей — стан qubit'а 1. Підготовка qubit'а один таким чином, а не просто
залишення його в нульовому стані, дозволяє алгоритму використовувати квантовий паралелізм у поєднанні з інтерференцією для отримання інформації
про функцію чорного ящика. Подивімося, що відбувається, коли qubit'и подаються до UF — gate чорного ящика: може відбутися кілька речей.
Якщо функція константна, то чорний ящик виконає певну операцію лише над qubit'ом один, незалежно
від стану нуля. У цьому випадку, оскільки UF не торкається qubit'а нуль і
не залежить від його стану, другий Hadamard тут просто скасовує те, що
зробив перший Hadamard. І ми виміряємо qubit у стані нуль. Розглянемо збалансовану функцію f_sub_2 як приклад, щоб побачити,
що UF робить із станом у цьому випадку. Коли x дорівнює нулю, f від x дорівнює нулю, а коли x
дорівнює 1, f від x дорівнює 1. Пам'ятаєш, що я розповідав про gate UF? Він приймає qubit 0
як наш вхідний стан x і виводить f від x на qubit'і 1. За умови, що qubit 1
починав у нульовому стані. Тож для цієї функції те, що UF робить із qubit'ом 1, залежить
від qubit'а 0. Якщо 0 є нулем, то qubit 1 залишиться в нульовому стані, що дає f
від x = 0. Якщо qubit 0 дорівнює 1, чорний ящик застосує not gate до qubit'а 1 і переведе
його в стан одиниці. Отже, f від 1 дорівнює 1. Це саме те, що робить контрольований not, або C-not gate. Gate
C-not приймає два qubit'и — керуючий qubit і цільовий qubit — і перевертає
стан цільового qubit'а, якщо керуючий qubit перебуває в стані одиниці. Але не робить нічого з цільовим, якщо керуючий
qubit перебуває в стані нуля. Отже, UF для F2 — це просто C-not на Q0 та Q1. Gate C-not
не зробить нічого з першим членом, оскільки керуючий qubit перебуває в стані нуль. Але в другому члені цей
нуль перевертається в одиницю, а ця одиниця — в нуль. І якщо ми винесемо знак мінус, ми побачимо, що стан qubit'а 1
не змінився. Але цей член набув знак мінус. Тому стан qubit'а 0 —
насправді той, що змінився. Він перейшов від |0⟩ + |1⟩ до |0⟩ -
|1⟩. Коли ми застосовуємо фінальний Hadamard до qubit'а 0, це перетворює його на стан 1. Тому, якщо функція в чорному ящику
— f_sub_2, ми виміряємо одиницю замість нуля. Виявляється, gate UF для іншої збалансованої функції f3 — це той самий
C-not gate, за яким іде not на qubit'і 1. Той фінальний not gate не впливає на qubit нуль. Тому коли функція
збалансована, ми виміряємо qubit 0 у стані одиниці в кінці circuit'а. Якщо ти не стежив за всім цим,
нічого страшного. Рекомендую пройти через це самостійно, щоб зрозуміти, як це працює. Головний момент тут — це те, що
відбулося, коли ми застосували C-not для двох збалансованих функцій. Qubit 0 використовувався лише як керуючий qubit для зміни
стану qubit'а 1. Інтуїтивно ти міг би подумати, що qubit 0 залишиться незміненим. І все ж якимось чином наші
операції над qubit'ом один насправді змінюють стан qubit'а нуль, змінюючи відносну фазу між двома частинами
його суперпозиції. Це явище відоме як механізм зворотного викиду фази, і воно
надзвичайно контрінтуїтивне, як і багато квантових явищ. Певним чином механізм зворотного викиду фази можна порівняти
з греблею на човні. Дія відштовхування води назад насправді рухає тебе вперед. Так само операції над
qubit'ом 1 насправді змінюють qubit нуль. Тепер ми можемо запустити алгоритм Deutsch на
Qiskit. Тут ми можемо вибрати, яку функцію помістити всередину чорного ящика — ми вибрали F3. Ось
схема circuit'а алгоритму, і ми можемо запустити його, як і раніше, з примітивом sampler. Встановимо кількість
samples лише на одиницю і подивимося, що ми виміряємо. У цьому випадку ми виміряли одиницю.
Отже, ми знаємо, що функція була збалансованою, що й очікувалося, оскільки чорний ящик містив функцію f3. Тож лише за один
запит ми змогли розрізнити ці два класи функцій.
Класичному алгоритму знадобилося б два запити для цього. Це показує скромну перевагу квантових
обчислень над класичними, але не дуже вражає. Лише один проти двох. Але алгоритм Deutsch
WEBVTT
все одно надзвичайно важливий для історії квантових обчислень, тому що він дав іскру, яка змусила інших
задуматися про більш масштабні та складні квантові алгоритми.
Це включає багатокубітне розширення алгоритму Deutsch, яке демонструє значно вражливішу квантову перевагу.
Воно називається алгоритмом Deutsch-Jozsa. Він розв'язує схожу задачу, але в цьому випадку функція чорного ящика,
про яку ми хочемо дізнатися, приймає n бітів як вхід і виводить один біт. Як
і раніше, нам гарантовано, що функція або константна — тобто вихідний біт завжди один або завжди нуль,
незалежно від вхідного бітового рядка, — або збалансована, тобто вихід дорівнює нулю для
половини вхідних бітових рядків і одиниці — для іншої половини. Звичайно, існують інші
функції, що відображають n бітів на один біт, які не є ні константними, ні збалансованими. Але в цій задачі нам
гарантовано, що жодна з таких функцій не знаходиться всередині чорного ящика. Та, що в ящику, гарантовано є або константною,
або збалансованою. Circuit Deutsch-Jozsa схожий на алгоритм Deutsch, але з більшою кількістю qubit'ів. Тут ми маємо
реалізацію алгоритму Deutsch-Jozsa для вивчення трьохбітної функції. Цього разу у нас є три qubit'и
для вхідного стану замість одного. І потім є цей останній qubit для вихідного стану. Як і раніше,
ми підготовлюємо всі вхідні qubit'и в стані |0⟩ + |1⟩, а вихідний qubit —
у стані |0⟩ - |1⟩. Потім, хоча математика трохи складніша для розуміння, принцип
залишається тим самим. Якщо функція константна, вона не залежатиме від трьох верхніх qubit'ів взагалі. Тому їхні стани
трансформуються назад до нуля після другого Hadamard'а, і наше вимірювання дасть трьохбітний рядок із самих
нулів. Але якщо функція збалансована, то коли ми вимірюємо qubit'и після Hadamard'ів, механізм зворотного викиду фази
призведе до того, що один або більше з цих бітів дорівнюватимуть одиниці. Це може бути не так легко побачити цього разу, але якщо ти пройдеш
через кожен крок самостійно, то незабаром переконаєшся, що так воно й має бути. Один спосіб перевірити це — спробувати обчислити
імовірність вимірювання всіх нулів для збалансованої функції. Ти маєш отримати імовірність, що дорівнює нулю. Запустимо
алгоритм Deutsch-Jozsa на квантовому комп'ютері за допомогою Qiskit. Найскладніший крок — мабуть, створення функції Deutsch-Jozsa.
Це буде наш чорний ящик, до якого ми робимо запит тут. Цей код генерує випадкову функцію Deutsch-Jozsa, яка
гарантовано є або збалансованою, або константною. Потім ми будуємо наш circuit Deutsch-Jozsa, вставляючи наш чорний ящик
сюди. Знову запускаємо circuit за допомогою sampler, і після вимірювання дивимося на
виміряні біти, щоб визначити, чи була функція збалансованою або константною.
Якщо всі нулі — константна. Але якщо в рядку є хоча б одна одиниця, то вона збалансована. У цьому
випадку ми отримуємо бітовий рядок 1 1 1.
Отже, ми знаємо, що функція була збалансованою. Сподіваюся, я дав тобі перший погляд на те, як квантові алгоритми
можуть використовувати цікаві та часто тонкі квантові явища, щоб отримати перевагу над класичними
алгоритмами. Ти, мабуть, також помітив, наскільки складно розробляти квантові алгоритми. Навіть самий перший
потребував багато творчості, щоб досягти лише скромної переваги над класичними методами. І з того часу, як з'явився перший алгоритм,
фізики та комп'ютерні науковці продовжують придумувати неймовірно винахідливі способи використання квантової механіки
на свою користь, включно з подальшими розширеннями та застосуваннями алгоритму Deutsch-Jozsa. Якщо хочеш
дізнатися про деякі з них, а також самостійно спробувати алгоритми Deutsch та Deutsch-Jozsa, переходь до
модуля за посиланням в описі, щоб розпочати. Дякую за перегляд, і побачимося наступного разу.